Figurez vous que si on lâche une mouche,
elle ne va pas forcément s'envoler...
Elle peut aussi tomber et s'écraser !
Bon... voir une mouche tomber comme ça dans la nature... ça reste assez exceptionnel.
Ces images ont été produites au cours d'une expérience menée par des chercheurs
de l'Institut des Sciences du Mouvement de Marseille.
Ils ont voulu étudier le vol de la mouche.
Enfin, plus précisément comment ce petit insecte contrôle sa trajectoire lorsqu'il est en chute libre.
Le protocole est simple : ils fixent la mouche au sommet d'une boîte
grâce à un petit bout d'épingle collé sur son dos,
tout en vérifiant que ça ne l'empêche pas de voler.
Ils lâchent ensuite la mouche d'un seul coup du haut de la boîte
et enregistrent sa trajectoire grâce à une caméra ultrarapide.
Voilà ce que ça donne :
Dans un environnement noir,
on voit qu'elle a réagi à sa chute...
elle galère pour attraper sa trajectoire...
Et bim ! Elle s'écrase.
Dans un environnement entièrement blanc,
elle se réveille plus tôt...
mais elle galère encore...
Et re-bim ! Elle s'écrase.
En revanche, dans un environnement à rayures,
hop ! elle se réveille,
très vite  elle se repère... et elle reprend son envol !
Ces trois manips durent moins d'une seconde, et elle montrent que la mouche
se repère dans l'espace avant tout grâce à sa vue.
Contrairement à nous, elle n'a pas d'oreille interne
qui lui permettrait de sentir ses mouvements
ou sa position dans l'espace.
Elle n'est donc pas sensible à la gravité !
... Ou plutôt à l'absence de gravité.
Vous savez cette agréable sensation que l'on a en chute libre...
Voilà ! donc on a regardé les mouches voler...
Oui bon, en fait non... En plus de mieux comprendre la physiologie de la mouche,
cette découverte permet par exemple d'imaginer
des systèmes de pilote automatique pour des drones, avec moins de capteurs,
qui utilisent uniquement des caméras
pour contrôler leur trajectoire.
... Donc on peut dire que c'est un sujet qui fait mouche ! :)
Quoi vous attendiez mieux comme chute ?
et n'oublie pas, abonne-toi !